este miércoles olímpico de muchísimas
emociones y terminó por una de las
pruebas más esperadas la de los 200
metros planos y fue el canadiense a
ondrej de gaz quien se impuso con un
tiempo de 19 puntos 62 por delante de
dos estadounidenses por una parte quedan
invernar aquí por otra nueva aislados
quien es el campeón mundial y bueno que
se esperaba fuera el ganador de esa
prueba porque partía precisamente como
favorito sin embargo feet de grass quien
se impuso y quien consigue su segunda
medalla en el tokyo 2020 después de
lograr el bronce en la prueba de los 100
metros planos otra final muy emocionante
fue la de los 400 metros vallas en la
que si es ni mala fe de eeuu se impuso
con un récord mundial 51.46 de hecho
batió su propio récord mundial que
habían puesto hace apenas un mes por
delante de la de muhammad una de las
favoritas y grana veterana también
estadounidense y en la tercera plaza del
bronce fue para fútbol de los países
bajos cuba que tuvo un muy buen día
también gracias a arlen lópez quien le
ha dado su segundo oro en boxeo aquí en
el tokyo 2020 tras vencer a venderme un
whitacre
el británico en la final de peso
semipesado y bueno segundo oro para cuba
en estos juegos olímpicos y bueno
todavía le quedan dos oportunidades más
con dos finales que quedan por
disputarse este viernes y por último
pues ya hay campeona olímpica de
skateboarding en la modalidad de park
uno de esos nuevos deportes olímpicos y
es japón el país que él genera en esto
yo su sumisa cura de 19 años se quedó
con el oro gracias a su primer round que
le dio la puntuación más alta irá a kiko
con a 12 años solamente tiene se quedó
con la plata y skype brawn de gran
bretaña con 13 años se quedó con el
bronce uno de los podios o el podio más
joven en la historia de los juegos
olímpicos